happy to be alive
that's how i feel that's how i try to
feel
most of the time
i just try to remind myself hey man
happy happy to be alive
you
know when i get to open my eyes it's
like okay
they want me back you know
that's how i feel a lot of times like
in the morning when i open my eyes it's
like all right
god wants me back you know or
they want to you know
they want to run it back okay
i made it you know
i think that's how i feel in the morning
when i open my eyes
like
okay
they
got called up again
um
what's going on happy day to you
uh
i got that big hair today baby um
i can feel it i feel because i knew when
i parked
and walked into the um
uh building
that i saw a bird look at me
i saw a bird
because birds move their neck and it's
so quiet you know it just it's so severe
and quiet
a bird can't slowly move its neck
you notice that
a bird is like has to be either at like
twelve o'clock nine o'clock
three o'clock
11 15.
but a bird can't just slowly migrate
like 11 15 11 16 11 17 11 a bird can't
slowly move its neck
but anyway i saw a bird look at my head
and i knew it was thinking
it was like a you know having nest
thoughts
i just felt that bird looked i knew it
was thinking oh damn look at that fella
that boy's got a damn hampton in on his
neck
that's what he when he saw this big hair
he's thinking all that boy
that fella's got a fair field in in
sweets
that i'd like to sleep in i could just
feel that bird looking at me and that's
when you know you got big hair
that's when you know that i got that
teepee today i got that wig one my [ __ ]
is native american i got that
literally that wig
and i'm having reservations
i'm always having reservations
um
but yeah i wake up and i'm like oh right
when i wake up
i'm like all right
life must want me back
and it's the same for you guys man life
wants you back
life wants you here today
you know life life
god the the powers the deities
of the universe made a choice and they
said yes to you
today
and that's
that's beautiful
you know
that is um
that's a welcome mat
you know when you open your eyes that's
a welcome mat
from the gods really
it's exactly what that is baby
gang baby praise god
and uh
yeah let's get into it
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
mountain
set me free
[Music]
just don't say
enjoy goodbye destination
[Music]
and the sea
[Music]
painting on the
[Music]
wall it's never too late
to come over
time slips away from you and me now
all right i don't know that audio felt
low to me a little but maybe it's uh
could have been just me
um that is come over by stevie starlight
and if you're not familiar with that
little dang uh
the cinnamon bear of the universe that
is stevie starlight then go get you a
dose
go have go have uh go have mother nature
cut you up a grandma stevie starlight
baby and put that in your snout a lot i
snout a luffa son
you'll be on yesamy street bro in no
time dawg
there's um
he's a beautiful listen and a beautiful
man stevie starlight
what's going on um
a lot
you know it's uh it's been a
there's a couple things i can tell you
about um
you know i've had
i had uh
i had oh i want to tell you actually
that
we have some new tour dates coming i do
want to announce them because i'm
excited
um
uh return of the rat is heading to
albuquerque new mexico
we will be there may 18th
midland texas may 19.
lubbock
texas
may 20
and dallas
texas may 21 right there beautiful
also savannah georgia we want to come
and see you and see how you're doing and
take your temperature
do that rectal momentum
that's june 2nd savannah ga augusta
ga june 3rd
june 4 montgomery
alabama
and june 5 columbus georgia
so there you go some beautiful choices
um excited to be going to those places
and uh
you can get tickets at theovon.com
t-o-u-r
and those will be on sale um for our
patreon on tuesday april 5th at 10 a.m
local
uh we have a small patreon but we are
very grateful uh to them for their
support over the years um
and then the artist pre-sale that goes
on sale on a wednesday april 6th at 10
a.m local time
and that is rat king
and so very grateful to you guys uh for
supporting
me
and then the general on sale will be
friday april 8th at 10 a.m local time so
wednesday april 2 you can start to get
them on rat king
will be the code
and i'm i'm excited about that man
i'm excited
you know it feel the world feels weird
right now
it feel
and i might be the only one i don't know
but to me something feels
it feels
i don't know
it feels disjointed some
you know it feels like uh
and i don't know if it's the world or if
it's just like our society
or if it's just america even
you know but things just feel
strange out there
you know is it just me or does it every
everything has a little bit of a
halloween edge i feel like
uh
like stores some stores they don't have
anybody even their work you know they're
like
you know stores don't have employees
we're understaffed
you know you get through your chipotle
and you get to the end of the line and
it's like they hired some
person who's
never even worked before
like has had you know and they're
they're just stan they don't even know
what to do
they're just standing there just eating
guacamole they have no idea
you ask them anything they kind of go
they get scared like there's like a
vampire seeing sunlight you know
they're just some i mean there's just
some
i don't know what's going on in the
world yeah i guess the
they say the workforce something is
going on there's not a lot of workforce
um
let me look that up so i'm not just is
there a
workforce
shortage there we
go in 2021 more than 47 million workers
quit their jobs
[Music]
many of whom were in search of improved
work-life balance and flexibility
increased compensation and a strong
company culture
huh
yeah and i don't know how factual this
is you know this could be
this is u.s chamber of commerce so we
have no idea if it's legitimate or not
but
i do notice you go play but i i walked
into a store the other day and the guy
it was like a little grocery store
and the guy asked me to work
for like 30 minutes he's like do you can
you just help out for like three i'm
like dude i'm just trying to get some
limes bro i'm just here for
i needed two limes and uh i'm like bro i
just trying to get some limes i mean i
used to work check out you know i used
to do
i mean i know bananas code is 4011.
but um
but
i'm here for a lump i'm not here to work
you know like that's how strange it's
getting that they're just if you're even
in a place
they're asking you to work it feels like
which is exciting i mean at least it's
great and i and you know i guess i'm
lucky that i don't have to take that
that you know 30 minutes i don't need
that employment at that half hour mark
but um
but damn it's just
it feels like the wild
i don't feel like the wild west
ah
and then where is everybody
that's another thing
you're like if nobody's working
where is what's going on
i don't know
and then you start thinking are people
bots are you running into bots
you know i watch people when they get in
their car a lot of times if they're
leaving me because
that's when i figure a bot
would have the toughest time
because there's a lot of little
intricacies when you get into a vehicle
and i don't think a bot could do that
real easily
you know you could easily see a bot like
oh i like the sunglasses you know
but
if you're running into like a bot human
i think if you watch them get in their
car they would have to really do it good
i'm happy i'm
it's tuesday you know so i don't know i
it's just getting everything feels
strange out there
and it feels kind of lawless
you know it feels lawless it feels like
the
you know people are just running red
lights it doesn't you know it's like
[ __ ] i'm running red light i mean i'm
running stops it's just like people are
doing what they want that's what it
feels like it feels like people are just
doing what they want
um
and i don't know maybe that's just
and it could just be my area
you know
um
but we have like the police live in fear
they're afraid it feels like to do their
jobs
uh
i don't know a lot of fear out there
a lot of fear out there um
and i'm sure you know that i'm not
trying to be a downer
just kind of saying i guess what's been
happening um
or just things i've been thinking about
what else dude i went to the
i went with david spade over to the
oscars uh after parties
and that was interesting
you know and [ __ ] oscars man you know
yeah you know i don't like all of that
[ __ ]
you know i don't like hollywood
or much of it
and um
but
getting to go with him and stuff like
that was real interesting
and i was overhead at his house we
watched the oscars at uh at david's home
and
they had the cr you know the chris rock
got hit
and i was thinking about that
and
i think there was
so many people have talked about it
right that and that's
that is what it is
but
i think there was like a um
there was like a moment where
part of the anger
was that here you have somebody who's
just saying something right chris rock
now i get he's jabbing at the guy's wife
i get that
um but also he's a comedian
he should be able to do that
or he should be able to take his risks
and i felt like it was a calculated risk
it felt super safe
um
but there was something about how
you saw
a guy walk up because he didn't like
what somebody else said
or for whatever reason it's hard to
really know the reason that will smith
had in his head
people said all kind of stuff he was
gaying out or he was gayed out
people said his wife was
you know they have a
um
you know they
do uh
foster cocking or whatever or when
people can make love to your wife you
know foster cox i don't know what it is
they do foster [ __ ]
uh
or [ __ ] fostering i don't know what it
is i don't i'm i'm not going to look it
up either because i have a blocker on my
computer but um
yeah so they said uh so anyway but there
was a guy who said something and then
you saw somebody
a rich guy on another rich guy
come and hit him
and then get an award for it
and it just kind of felt like this is
what it this was the this is where i
ended up really feeling the most anger
at the end of it all
was it was just really towards hollywood
towards the oscars towards the whole
[ __ ] machine of all that [ __ ]
it was like hey
we if somebody can hit somebody else
they can do whatever they want
they could say this man can speak or not
speed
so
and we'll we'll give that guy an award
and then
this is the craziest part
all of hollywood will stand there and
applaud the guy
as if the
the
the [ __ ] up thing he did didn't even
happen
and it was kind of like a microcosm i
think of everything that's been going on
you know
um
so many people feel like their reality
is neglected by hollywood
that uh
since hollywood owns a lot of the media
and and mainstream media that they just
uh
they just
that they're so powerful that if they
want to act like something didn't happen
they can just brush right over it
which they do all the time pick and
choose what they think
um
[Music]
or when they think something is
important or what they think is
important
uh
so i think there was a lot of that in
there for me
and i hope chris rock sues the oscars i
would sue the oscars i would sue
everybody in that [ __ ] you know
um
that's what i would do
because yeah they just that that's what
it was for me it was like
here's this powerful machine saying once
again
oh we determine how
if the way you see things is real or not
almost
or we think we determine it
because we all saw somebody hit somebody
and then
get an award then give an insane speech
and get a standing ovation it was like
they were trying to make us believe that
it didn't happen
in a way
which goes along with the whole pandemic
thing there's that all of that ties in
there
like oh you're gonna make me
you're really trying to bend me out of
the fact that reality is happening
so anyway that's kind of where some of
that landed for me
and maybe that's obtuse kind of
but maybe it's not dude i'm just here
for limes
okay i'm just i walked in here for two
limes and now i'm an assistant manager
that's what's going on
um
what else what else is happening
i know that chris rockshit is old news
and uh
and it was wild because spade took me to
like a fancy party
you know he took me to a fancy party
dude everybody was in that [ __ ]
kardashians [ __ ] uh
um
kevin bacon's was in there everybody was
in that leonardo uh
dicaprio and da vinci
both of them were i mean they had seance
in one room they had damn spirits coming
out of the back christopher columbus was
in that [ __ ]
everybody was in there
um kobe i think kobe showed up for a
half hour
it was uh
they were that's how fancy it was
they were recollecting people
and they were showing up
you know ed asner was in that [ __ ] who
else
um
i don't even know anybody else fam i
think i saw jesus over there by the uh
getting some watermelon punch i mean it
was they had everybody in there
you know or a lot of fancy names that's
who they had in there um
but that was just fun kind of just to
see how the other half lives you know
uh
i mean hollywood really scares me and
and it has for a while just because they
you know once you work for people you're
not allowed to have a lot of your own
thoughts
um
and i and and i think we all feel
there's a lot of fear out there for that
kind of stuff
is am i allowed to really
express what i really feel
or really am thinking
um
when these powerful companies and
machines they just
they'll try to manipulate stuff or just
gloss over things that seem very real
just to have things the way that they
believe they should be
anyway
i'm kind of rambling man
what else i went out to interview sugar
shawn out there and
he's a ufc guy fighter guy
and uh did that out in phoenix
and he's a real villain of the ufc kind
of in a weird way
you know he have that villainous side
he's the
he's like this
i don't want to say he's like a carnival
snake kind of he's not a
no he just like he's so fast
he's like uh
[Music]
i don't know i can't tell if he
sometimes if he's trolling things or if
he's just being himself you know and
he's just
he's very open you know he's in an open
relationship he's very open about
exactly what he thinks and feels um
he's a pretty fascinating guy to be
around and and uh
so i was grateful to get to go over
there and hang out with him and just
spend some time with him um
[Music]
what else is going on
uh
what's going on with me um
you know i've been honestly feeling like
a lot of fear recently in my own life
uh
just uncertainty
you know i've been having such a tough
time making decisions
even just the smallest ones
it's like
man i'll just i'm just so afraid
something inside of me is so afraid to
decide
and i don't know if it's i'm afraid that
i'll make the wrong choice
um
[Music]
as much as it is maybe there's just part
of me that's just afraid to
commit
i don't know
i'm just kind of thinking about that
if it's one or the other you know
am i afraid to commit or am i just
afraid to decide
if i'm afraid of making the wrong choice
or am i afraid of committing
it's interesting how those because those
two things are really big and different
but both of those are parts of
making a decision
um
so i've been struggling with that a lot
you know i've been feeling kind of a
little bit unsafe and uncertain in the
world
and so maybe that also adds to the fact
of uh
of
me feeling like the world is all over
the place
um
[Music]
and some of that i think you know i'm
still off my i'm still not taking
antidepressants so i'm still trying to
uh
to stay off of them
you know and i'm gonna i guess just keep
seeing how that can work or not um
you know i'm in contact with doctors and
and that sort of thing and therap and
doing therapy but i'm just you know i'm
trying to be brave in that instance
because i don't want i just i really
don't want to go back on them
you know i finally got this lid of these
medicine lit this medicine hat
off of my head and so
so much more feelings and thoughts could
come out
and
i think part of me has really been
enjoying
[Music]
getting some of that out of my system
you know just getting whatever that
turmoil is that dirty bubble
that
it's like a sick chowder that's just
been sitting on a
in a damn um
crock pot
and y'all just want to empty that [ __ ]
out
because it affects how my cafeteria
smells you know what i'm saying
it affects how the rat because if you
know
if i can get that the gunk out of the
engines
if i can get the uh
the nastiness
if i can get whatever's stuck in that s
drain or whatever it's called or p curve
or whatever
and shout out to all my plumbers out
there but if i can get
the s trap or whatever it is
then i can
i can feel like i'll have a smoother
flow inside of me um
and that's been that whole journey with
the ayahuasca and the staying off
antidepressants and
uh
we'll talk about more of it
i want to tell you also though right now
we got to pay the bills
i want to say that uh everybody have
different fitness goals
you might have some yours might be able
to be you want to be able to do a um
lift up your grandson or something look
at them
you know hold them above your head
some of y'all may be really struggling
your fitness goal may be to uh
to stay you know to be able to stand up
and talk to somebody or to go bird
watching
or to uh play hoops again maybe you've
fallen on an illness or have um
what's it called mercury poisoning
well i'll tell you this fitbod
is here
to help you with your goals with your
path to being
your best
that path looks different for everybody
but fitbod creates a program based on
your unique goals experience and
equipment
their algorithm uses data and analytics
to build on your last workout and
maximize results
whether you exercise three days a week
or twice a day
every workout is scientifically proven
to be better than the last
fit bod it's like having that teammate
that pnc baby that potential crime
that's right there for you they track
your muscle recovery
balancing your workout plan with a
variety of exercises to avoid
overworking certain muscles that's right
you can access your personalized routine
on the easy to use mobile app
and start making progress on your goals
whenever wherever you are so if you
somewhere you can do it
it's like having 24 7 access to a
personal trainer you pop it open you
turn it on and bam
you're getting assisted you have a
partner
build your fitness habits and become a
better version of yourself with fit bod
get 20 off your subscription to try out
the app for free
when you sign up now at fitbo dot m e
slash t-h-e-o
that's 25 off your subscription when you
sign up today at fit bod
dot m-e-t-h-e-o
you also you got to know about the zebra
baby
the zebra you know what i'm saying that
party donkey you know what i'm talking
about
that stripe maybe that little prison
mule baby you know what i'm saying
you've seen the bars on that bad boy
well with more folks hitting the road
more accidents are happening
and insurance rates are going up
luckily for us our friends at the zebra
are here to help
they make it so easy to save hundreds on
car or home insurance in just minutes
the zebra compares car and home quotes
for every major insurance company side
by side
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision
because that's what you need sometimes
the facts you got a fact over here you
got a fact over there you got a fact on
the roof you got a fact under the rug
but they're not lined up
so you can't see the facts all at once
they're going to help you the zebra can
help
show support
for our show by going to this special
url the zebra.com slash t-h-e-o and get
your free quote today
that's at the
zebra.com slash theo
all right um
what else is happening
what's happening with you guys
what's happening with you
you know it's funny sometimes i sit and
i think about
you actually i i think about
you
listening to this
and
and who you are
i just one i just want you to know that
i think about that sometimes i think
well
i'm saying stuff and it's leaving out
here and it's going into someone's ears
into someone's time
and that's important to me
you know uh
yeah i want to just say thank you
and
and i'll try to do a
a better job
or as good of a job as i can of valuing
the fact that
you spend your time you
you know you let me up in the mirror
holes you know what i'm saying player
you know what i'm saying no i'm a dog
but
you know what i'm saying i'm in both
those [ __ ] right now baby we got a
gang bang going on your brain son right
now
whoo
somebody better put a condom on these
words baby because we [ __ ] getting in
there on both sides of it
uh no i just want to say thank you that
that means something to me you know that
i think about you
you know i want to
we had actually we had a call come in
you know
we had this call come in which i thought
was nice
let's hear this here
hey melissa that's melissa from utah
right there and good to hear from you
you sound like a woman you sound good
uh i was just listening to your
brotherly love podcast and you were
talking about autism and
um i have a 15 year old son that has
autism
kind of non-verbal but when he was
diagnosed about
14 years ago
what you were talking about is what kind
of pulled me through his diagnosis it
was like
i came to this conclusion that
he had skills that were needed for the
future our technology has gone so far so
fast
and his brain was so fast oh yeah
you got that computer baby darling you
know
you get that little digital toddler baby
or adult toddler now onward
and intelligent and i was like
you know these are the kids that our
future is going to need to carry us
through
um so
i just want to thank you for that
it was amazing thank you so much for
confirming that like what i thought 15
years ago
some other people are kind of thinking
now oh you're welcome
yeah i don't know why i i i just yeah
i'm glad that you have uh
that you have your son
and i'm glad that you um
obviously have a commitment to raising
him
and
and to being uh a part of his life and
to finding ways to see him
that make
um
that make y'all's relationship
as important and
um
as valuable as it can be to you
[Music]
yeah i think it's
i think literally in the
you know
in a hundred years it's going to be 11
people with autism battling a computer
to
see if humanity
carries on
i could easily see that
and it's all yeah
and an amazon
van shows up and drops off the web
whatever weapons they're gonna use
and um
and that'll be it
you know a referee will there even be a
referee there probably will
probably somebody from new york hoboken
or something
you know some guy
or from you know
you know
uh
some you know some um
maybe a boat captain or somebody like
that somebody who's a little gruff you
know who's gonna call it like it is
you know who's just gonna
you know who's gonna take some smoke
breaks though also you're gonna need
that ref that's not afraid to [ __ ]
sit out there and puff it out
um
but thank you thank you for calling in
and and uh
and thank you for being a mother
we need them out
there um
what else you guys had some calls about
things that are going on in my life as
well
uh here's one that came in
as always the hotline is
985-664-9503 i feel a lot of anxiety
right now about
what to communicate with you guys
um
[Music]
because it's you know there's been a lot
kind of
just in my head and in my heart and so
it's tough to know
how to get it out and do it in an
organized fashion um
all right let's take this call
what's up theo it's gavin from ritarco
um
new mexico what's up gavin and good to
see you man from rioto
and i never heard of that spot baby but
i'm glad y'all are uh
[ __ ] i don't know where that is baby
onward
so that is i had a question about doing
the ayahuasca i've done a dmt and is
there anything close to it you know gmt
only lasts a couple minutes when you
freaking
fly through crazy tunnels and meet
different people like there's always a
guy with a backwards hat in mind and
i don't know it's weird been a handful
of times um
it's a it's pretty delightful you come
out of it you just want to hug people
and feel so good you feel like you know
there's actually an after after life
like going through that i just wanted to
know the similarities with it because
it's kind of the same thing
um
thank you for the question there i
appreciate it
and um
you know my experience dmt was very much
like somebody
kicked you like beat you in the head
with a uh dave and busters
that's what it's like
it was like two angry gay dudes attacked
you at a
ga at a dave and busters
because you're seeing all these crazy
shapes there's a lot of rainbows there's
some bears there's some stuff that look
like a orifice or whatever
it has a very kind of a
booty carnival
type of
dirty
magnificent
um colorful
it's like somebody
it's like
god hit you with a mirror but he hits
you hard and he hits you fast
and the cops showed up
and all that you know and the cops are
from heaven and hell and it all happened
in a matter of minutes
that to me was dmt
a lot of that
and you end up [ __ ] sitting there
talking to like an oyster or something
just some [ __ ] that you're like i don't
know what this is you know they got a
koala over there and he's puffing
winston's bruh he's doing his best
you know when he's out of work probably
you know sure chipotle is trying to hire
him
to work next to that vamp kid who can't
handle the freaking
oh you ask him one question he's like oh
you don't know
i don't know i need to sleep
um
that was dmt for me man dmt was like uh
somebody took a pinball machine
and buried you in it
they opened the glass up and put you in
there and the game is still going on
there's still somebody hitting the
paddles the balls are scooting around
and it's multiball somebody accessed a
multi-ball so they're all and then
you're just laying and they put the
glass back on
and you're laying in there
face down
that to me is dmt that's what dmt was
like
it's a couple minutes you come out of it
you're in maui
the guy who's doing it with you you met
at a smoothie stand you know he's a good
guy
he gave you some magnesium
you know it's uh it is what it is
ayahuasca is
ayahuasca is like a key i think
it's like an invitation
you take it
you sit there
you're meditating
there's no party about it there's
nothing like uh
we're gonna do this in a back room at a
party that's not
now you can still do it in a back room
but
it's more of a experience
and it's a longer experience
and it's really
you start to learn about yourself
you learn some truths about yourself
you know i was sitting there and i mean
people are like did you go to peru did
you go to you know
myanmar or whatever
like dude i did that [ __ ] right off the
101 bruh
i did that i was i was probably
180 yards from a popeye's
chicken
you know in a dsw shoes dude i could see
there were moments in some of my visions
and stuff that somebody who you know
you know walk by with a damn pair of
birkenstocks on so
i was
you know i wasn't out in the abyss but
the environment i was in was really nice
uh in the sense that it was it had a
great shaman and great people doing it
and i'm sitting in there and you take
the medics you take the medicines and
it's almost like your heart starts to
dream
or
think
and it's really wild because you start
to get thoughts that come out of your
it's almost like they come out of the
time
that's trapped
of you
it's like your heart gets a brain
um
you know i remember
sitting there and uh
and you just start to go it's like
it's like a best friend shows up
and starts to share stuff with you that
you're willing to hear
because you um
usually because you've been suffering
with something
you know
oh
and so it starts to kind of unearth some
of that
and you go through the different
experiences and you're like man that was
a lot you know i learned a lot of stuff
about myself
it's like therapy but you don't have to
do a lot of the heavy lifting
i mean it's like the goddess you know
the
like god brings the wood right up to you
you know the fire well you don't have to
go out and chop
you just open the door and it's all
firewood you can't even see the world
it's just
all your firewood is right there
and the gu and god has chopped it for
you
and so you could it's just so at that
point it's really an invitation it's
like how much do you want to know
that's what it feels like to me
how much do you want to know
my last experience man i went and
you know i'd really been struggling with
a lot of stuff about my mother uh and my
relationship with my mother
and my inability to have a connection
with my mother a deep connection
you know i've always wanted it
and um
and so i'm sitting there under the
ayahuasca and
and i've always struggled in
relationships commitment
i've really always struggled
and
while i'm under this ayahuasca while i'm
in the experience of the medication
i realize that the reason i have trouble
getting into a relationship or being
committed
well there's two reasons one
is that part of me is still waiting for
this relationship with my mother to
really
um
come through
there's part of me that's still like
this young kid that's still just
standing there waiting
for his mother
to really
connect with him
um
and so it's really hard for me
to make another commitment to another
woman it's really hard for me
uh
and i didn't know it was because there's
a part of me that's still just literally
standing there waiting
and that sounds kind of crazy but
when you're under the medication it
makes a lot of sense
because it really activates the inner
child in
you and you really get to see what the
very young you the formative you what he
what he or she went through
um
and you see why they went through it and
how it affected them and then how that
affects you now
it's almost like as an adult you're a
plant
but on ayahuasca you get to go back to
the seed
and you get to look in the seed
and the seed gets to communicate the
seed communicates with you
the you the you the early you the
formative you um
but so it's a lot different in that
sense you really get to sit there and
and
and be with a lot of the things that
have made you uncomfortable but now
you're able to see okay this is why i
behave this way as an adult
because this happened when i was young
and you always can kind of
in therapy sometimes you'll talk about
those things but to really have a real
connection between them and to really
feel that connection is pretty powerful
uh
and also
it's a it's a
it's an invitation in a way because
ayahuasca is an invitation
because it's really how much of that
stuff do you want to learn and go into
because it feels like there's a lot of
it
my second experience i sat there for
probably
oh i can't even tell you
i mean just tons of time you just cry i
mean i was just grieving just crying
i was grieving like um
you know when i was 12 or 10 my brother
he got to go live with my grandparents
and
that sounds like a small thing but
that broke my heart
it broke my heart as a kid
that my mother let him go
it bro i mean it really
because he was the closest thing that i
felt to uh to love you know or to a real
friend or something and
[Music]
and here was my mother and she let him
go
just do what he wanted like he was an
adult it just was
and that [ __ ] broke my heart man so
but there's a lot of things inside of
you that you've been resilient through
and but you're able to go and look at
those things and let
kind of let the air out of some of those
balloons you know
it's like your soul gets to fart kinda
you know you're able to go and unpack a
lot of these things that really could
have really
and and probably had a big effect on
your life and how you behave now
so anyway it's tough because it's hard
for me to go into some of that
you know a lot of it's real painful i
went and spoke with my mom
after the holidays about uh
you know about some about
a lot of the feelings i was having
and i you know and about how much i felt
neglected really and
and it was hard man i'm glad i was able
to give myself a voice but it was it was
it was tough
because it was also a long time ago you
know and
um and so you don't want to damage the
person you're talking to or upset you
know you don't but you do want to share
what's going on
uh and what you're feeling and learning
um
so that's ayahuasca man if you want
ayahuasca you're gonna go down a real
or you could go down
you know a real
rabbit hole
a real invitation to say okay how much
because you can keep going and doing it
and that's where i'm at now i don't know
if i want to go back sometimes
right now
uh
i mean the the the
the last time i went man it was it was
cathartic
but it was damn painful man
it was painful it was cathartic in the
way you sit there and you know
you
[Music]
you cry for the things that you get
those tears all the [ __ ] that's in you
get it out
you get it out you cook it right up out
of your system
um
but it's a lot of work i mean it is it's
the hardest thing i've ever had to do
it's like i i
you know i would imagine it's like boot
camp or something but for your
for your heart and for your
soul and stuff so
um
i don't know if that does a good job of
explaining it but that's some of the
differences i noticed between them one
of them is a real
one of them is like going to a carnival
and the other one is like
going to
it's like going into an ocean
so
that's my thoughts on the difference
between i think dmt and ayahuasca is
ayahuasca can really
it can re i mean dmt shows you that
you know dmt's are kind of like a
firework kind of but ayahuasca is a damn
[ __ ]
jesus
it's a fire
it's a fire man
um
what else do we have that came in
you know you can always hit the hotline
985-664-9503
um
you know i want to unpack a little bit
more of the relationship between myself
and my mother and that sort of thing i
just don't know if i'm
if i'm
in a space to share some of that uh
and how you know i just i want to be
make sure that i'm well about it before
i kind of share it sometimes to be fair
to myself
um what else we got in here
uh oh i was talking about a wife hunt
and that wife hunt baby yeah you know i
would like to have a family i would like
to have a wife
and get me a wife you know
and nothing illegal or nothing i ain't
them
you know ain't kidnapping nobody or
nothing like that
but i would like to have me a real wife
so
i gotta start thinking about that
um
and now you could k i wouldn't kidnap a
woman ever but you could if you wanted
to you know set a butterscotch out there
on a concrete or something on the
sidewalk and then she come by and get it
a lady get it
and she's eating that [ __ ] and you you
hit you know
you go over there and you know maybe
give her a little massage or something
if she's okay with it you massage her
scalp or something
you know get that vibe going
because that scalp baby you can massage
a woman's head baby that's the that's
really the that's the
the that's the major tit
is a woman's scalp bro
the right the the front tit some [ __ ]
are just
those are [ __ ] um
those are just some red herrings baby
those aren't the real deal that master
tit is you feeling a woman's scalp bro
that's one thing you learn
you start massaging or scratching a
woman's head a little damn baby
that's that master tit son
that thing is the real leader
them other things they're just quartz
but the real leader dog is that head
that's that master tit that thing's got
a lot of feeling in it
but then front them little front bunnies
baby them little sippers
those little a cup hitters or whatever d
cups whatever they have those things are
[ __ ]
that's just that's tricking you
the master tit is that head
praise god
all right i want to let you know that uh
it can be hard sometimes to see the
light at the end of the tunnel
it really can you know that especially
if you're in a tunnel
jesus
but especially if you have high interest
debt
and sometimes it can be even harder to
ask for help that's where upstart comes
in
saying goodbye to high interest credit
card debt is the one of the first steps
toward financial independence
but the interest month after month can
feel like you're in a never-ending
hamster wheel ham gang
that's where upstart comes in
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest debt
all online with simple and easy to
understand payments upstart has helped
over 1.8 million customers on their path
to financial freedom that's powerful
you can check your rate in minutes
for loans between 1000 to 50 000 without
impacting your credit score wow that's
amazing
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com
t-h-e-o
that's upstart.com
theo to check your rate today
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to
upstart.com
t-h-e-o
look when you sell something to someone
it's it's hectic
you got to do you got to do this you got
to buy you got to do this and that you
got to make sure it gets here you go to
the uh post office it's a nightmare you
know all of that hectic
well
ship station can help
since online shopping is all we do now
basically ship station
will make sure that you never have to
worry about getting your orders or your
shipping wrong again
they handle all your needs affordably
and painlessly
they manage every order from amazon to
ebay to etsy
on your or on your website
from anywhere and you can even do it
from your phone they have a beautiful um
interface on there beautiful
ship more and less time with ship
station
use my offer code t-h-e-o to get a
60-day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in th eo
ship station make ship happen
but yeah any let me hear here's a call
hi theo
um i wanted to ask just i guess out of
curiosity um
you've been open recently about wanting
to settle down and
wanting something more serious
so i was just wondering if you had any
deal breakers like if you had any like
for example
uh do you have like a restriction on an
aged gap like if somebody let's say was
around
25 years old
and
was interested in going out with you or
something like that
do you have like a immediate like red
flag like a restriction like with age
gaps or anything like that like would
you not go out with somebody
um
with
more of an age gap
like greater than 10 years or something
okay i see what you're saying uh
ramifications that's what you're saying
um you know i made a list a while back i
met a lady on a plane and she said make
a list of what you want in a
a wife and a uh
straight woman
and
man i wish i had it on me today i don't
have it with me i'll bring it in next
time
um
but yeah i don't do i have an age gap i
would probably say you know you want to
be age appropriate so probably
25 and up
i think
you know i mean
look my dad mom my dad was 38 years
older than my mother
so
so damn i could see a toddler right now
and lit and be like hey i'm just
trying to gauge their personality you
know uh
but
so i want to be age appropriate i think
or whatever i don't know you don't know
what love is but
sometimes you do so i'd say probably
over 25 for sure
um
what else
hair
um
smart
um
[Music]
loving i would say somebody that likes
to you know
hug and
be
loving
um
somebody that's going to be a good
mother
that really is key i want my children to
have a good mother
even if
you know i would hope that things will
work out between me and my wife but
i want my children to have the best
mother that they can
um
[Music]
yeah that is really important to me so
it's funny sometimes i notice when i'm
looking for a wife that [ __ ] got me a
little bent up
when i'm looking for a wife uh
or when i'm looking for a you know
looking for attractions i'm not out
there like you know sharpening a sword
that says wife on it and [ __ ] like that
but you know
when i am
thinking about dating or looking at
women or spending my time
i
my main thought really is
is this woman going to be a good mother
i think i mean i have i have obviously
other some attraction things you know
i would like both eyes i don't care that
much but i would love it
um
i would like a woman who likes to stay
uh athlete you know stay busy get some
sweat going
um those things are just good for life
you know uh
and a woman is understanding because
[ __ ] you know me boy if you listen to
this podcast you know i need a lot of
understanding
so those are a couple of things i'll
bring my list in
um
and
but those are a couple things that i
think about
you know i look in a woman's eyes a lot
of times
and you can see
and when i look at their eyes i think if
i was a child would i like looking at
that woman's eyes
and that
uh
i know that my wife will have that i may
sound crazy to some people but
the childhood i had didn't have that
comfort in it
i didn't have that comfort when i
you know from my mother from her look
and so i want my child to have that
and
so that's one thing that i kind of look
for i think
so yeah somebody with no eyes probably
or
that
you know doesn't have like a
warmth in them
um probably may not be the best fit for
me you know i know
that's something that i need or
something i would like we'll see what
god wants you know but that's something
that i would like
um
what else
oh we had another call here uh that came
in i know this episode's all over the
place but the truth is i've been all
over the place
um
you know i'm still really working to try
and feel better to feel well
uh i felt uncertain a lot of times and
um
you know there's days where i want to do
the podcast but i can't because i don't
feel
i don't feel well
if i'm real honest and i want to you
know
put my best foot forward
and sometimes it's hard you know
everything's hard i'm not complaining
but i'm just saying
um
it feels sometimes
i don't know it feels
this world this today it doesn't feel
sometimes like it wants you that much
i don't know if that's a crazy statement
i'm not trying to sound cryptic or
anything like that
um
and it could just be american society it
could just be la because i've been out
here for 10 days
so that could also be it
and honestly i bet that has a lot to do
with it um
yeah a couple calls came in you know we
had rushed on the topic of uh
of is it okay to have your brother teach
you masturbation
to teach you that touchy touchy that one
hand touch you know what i'm saying
that seek and go seek you know what i'm
saying
that uh
that singular freeze tag you know i'm
saying you're rich you're rich you're
rich you know what's going on baby
yakking off yakking off yakking off
yaking
yakking off
i think it'd be funny if when people
said jack and if they had to close their
eyes when they said it
look man i want to be
i want to be honest with you guys i've
been
jacking off
okay
i just don't want there to be any lies
here and i want you to know that i have
been
jacking off
all right
because i think if you had to do that
less people would do it
or what about this if you jerked off the
next day you had to keep your your eyes
would just close for no reason a lot of
times
that those are little governors i wish
god had put in the system
if you jerked off your eyes with clothes
for no reason for about a half hour the
next day or you know here and there for
20 minutes you're just talking to
somebody about the baseball game dude
the blue jays wow crushed it huh yeah
tiger sucked this year and then suddenly
you're just in the dark dude you're just
standing here at lunch
everybody's like what ha what's going on
man and you can't open your eyes and
he's like oh
you've been jacking off haven't you
or if you jacked off then the next day
you had to do thumbs up all day
so people knew i just wish there was a
little bit more something built in our
system um
but i've been jacking off man i'll be
real honest with you dude or
jacking off as people say with their
eyes closed
i've been doing jacking off and i wish i
hadn't
you know i got caught up in it yesterday
and
i was looking at some pornography man uh
just felt horrid and i just don't like
it it makes me feel horrible about
it just makes me feel like bad
the [ __ ] is cringe kinda
you know it's cringe
it's dirty
and i just
i don't know sometimes i get home at
night i'm alone
and i feel uncomfortable
and i want to feel good so
what helps you do that jacking off
but that's okay man you know i've been
hitting a few meetings recently
that's been
good you know trying to take care of
myself
which is all we can do
and if that's what you're doing
i've been jacking off
um all right we had a cold people call
though about is it okay for your brother
to teach you masturbation you know we
had a fella calling a few weeks ago that
his brother
had taught him how to do it
had taught him how to work that wand you
know what i'm saying had taught him how
to hog that wart baby had taught him how
to adore that griffin you know what i'm
talking about full slytherin
this fellow's brother had taught him how
to jerk off jerikov
but uh
and is that okay and i thought it was
interesting because it takes me to a
tribal place
where
at least if your brother or father
teaches you to masturbate then at least
it feels like it's a
it's okay it's normalized
whereas if you're secretly doing it
behind a big rock in the desert or
something or
you know if your cousin comes over and
he's you know
uh
and and he leaves a nudie mag out or
something
and then you doing it you're jerking off
you know then that's that you know
that might not be good or if you learn
it from like a crazy guy at school you
know somebody sneaks into the
schoolhouse one day
you know during
recess
and t you know and just tells everybody
about jerking off and then runs out
you know and you know and dies in a
house fire or something
that ain't cool
you know because then you might feel
ashamed every time somebody lights a
match you might
you know
you know skeet out a little
you know or bet your penis might belch a
little or burp a little seed
but anyway man what i'm telling you is
that people responded to that to the
brother masturbation is that okay let's
hear what they had to say here we go
bro this is to your question this is
tristan what's up tristan good to hear
you dude and it's uh you sound like a
nice guy brother and we're happy you're
alive baby onward uh this is your to
your question about
if your brother should ever teach you to
masturbate and i say
hell nah bro
hell nah
okay
well you might not be uh
you yeah everybody's allowed to have an
opinion and i don't know i don't know
what the world thinks
i think that's outrageous
oh come on bro but i do appreciate you
gang baby same man
all right let's uh let's get another one
right here here we go
hi theo
i am just calling in because i was
listening to your episode about brothers
teaching each other to jerk off
okay it was not a full episode madam it
was a part it's a conversation
and it's a great conversation
you know it's really important who do
you want teaching your son to jerk off
huh
it's a great question do you want their
brother someone who loves them and cares
about them
and has an effect on them and has a a a
a
a way that they look up to them to teach
them or do you want some miscreant out
there at the milk shop huh
you want some guy who's just been
working at the grocery for a half hour
you want that guy teaching your kid to
man you don't say who do you want
teaching them
who do you want
you want one of his school buddy you
want a little eric you want eric
teaching him
eric's little crazy ass huh
who don't wear no shoelaces in his boots
you want him teaching them
onward
and i think you need a little female
perspective
so not only is it the brother's
responsibility to teach the brother i
think it's the sister's responsibility
to teach the sister
that's how it went in my family i'm not
going to get into details because i know
there's a lot of creeps that listen to
this podcast yes there are
but
it goes for the women too
gang gang baby
that thang thang you know so look i'm
saying this stuff is more popular than
you think obviously
here we had one more call about it here
we go
theo no
and there you go that's that lady was
really adamant about it man that's
really really adamant about it all right
lastly we had an advice that came in for
tyrell tyrell had this question last
week hey siobhan this is uh ty rouse i'm
uh
just driving home back to california and
i was listening to your podcast thought
i'd get some uh some stuff off my chest
you know i've been single for quite some
time now i've been having sex in the
last
i don't know two years and i i just need
some some advice man on
how do i
get back in the game how do i you know
get my
my willy wet if you will and
i think it's kind of a it's a simple
question honestly tyrell and um
and we have a couple of questions a
couple of options for you
theo yo this is uh gatlin whitney out of
salt lake city utah
gatlin baby and that's a gun name
you know that
we used to have twins bus out there in
folsom louisiana named bow and arrow i
remember
and that's weapon
that's weaponry
gang gang brother um i was calling about
that the guy from last week on end
saying he wasn't getting any ladies
and i kind of had that same issue for a
while and what i figured out is what you
got to do is get down to the gym
it's going to run about 10.99 such a
convenience fee but what you're going to
do you're going to get real comfortable
in that gym you're going to work on the
body but not only that you're going to
see all them fancy females there
and then you start making small talk oh
how long are you going to work on this
machine can i use it after you can you
come grab me when
and then they're familiar with you they
become friends with you you start
talking two months goes by and you
between them shoot knock and poop damn
there you go
friends [ __ ] each other and i hate to
say that out loud but it's true and it's
been true for a long time
let's take one more suggestion here uh
for uh tyrell
what up tio i got some advice for your
boy tyrell about his uh
his drought
boy needs to just keep swiping right
you know i had a wise man once say if
you're ever going through a crowd with
the women
you just throw down the first ugly one
that's down and that's smashed the
streak there you go you could try to
hook up yeah with a lady that you're not
attracted to you know maybe
it just might start that energy going
you know um obviously you want to treat
her well and you know be
just be realistic with her you know just
let her know it's for sex only or you
know that you're just not you know
because sometimes you don't want to get
somebody hopes up if you can keep them
down if you can keep somebody's hopes
down
i mean [ __ ] my shoulders hurt from
keeping my hopes up baby i know that
they are so were
um
all right
i appreciate you guys man
i want to say thank you for being a part
of uh
just of my life and week and in my time
and for caring about my life um
and caring about the lives of people
that call into this show
and if you're out there struggling with
something you're going through a tough
time like
it's normal
everybody is
you know
i mean
even though sometimes i wake up and that
you know life's that gay life's chosen
you again you know it's tough
it's tough to say all right i'm gonna
play you know i'm gonna move i'm gonna
get going again i'm gonna give it
another shot
but you can do it
you know um
you can do it
and we don't give up
that's what we don't do and uh
and just if you're going through
something man i love you you know a
woman i love you and
and you love you too
you love you too don't forget that
there's a part of you inside of you that
absolutely
loves you
that loves you
there is a part of you inside of you
that absolutely
loves
you
and that's true
and i believe that
um
[Music]
and there's a part of me inside of me
that absolutely loves me
and i
i gotta try and live hear that voice
more
um
because that's a powerful voice
but you guys be good to yourselves man
you deserve it and uh
and thank you for hitting the hotline
985-664-9503
i'm excited about the new tour dates
thank you so much for your for your uh
for your support and um
you know what it is let's go out like we
came in baby gang
gang
[Music]
higher than a mountain
set me free
just don't say goodbye
[Music]
it's you and me
this is stevie starlight guys
[Music]
[Applause]
it's never too late
to come over
time slips away
so don't hesitate to come over
why
all right and i always awkwardly close
that out um
gang baby you guys be good to yourselves
we got the new bobble heads if you want
to grab them they're available out there
theovon uh store
tickets get them only at theovonn.com
t-o-u-r
want to make sure you don't get swindled
and um
and that's it
you know that's it for this week
uh we're doing our best you're doing
your best
and that is a lot sometimes that is and
that is enough
and um
you guys be good to yourself baby gang